let's get to some audience questions I
think this week's are particularly good
first one is from penny are people
generally aware of their surroundings or
are they too distracted sort of depends
what you mean there are so many
situations where the norm blends into
the background so that when something
unusual actually happens people are very
very slow to react and you see this so
often in situations where there's a sort
of a crime being committed if you go to
the same place every day and you drive
to work the same way sometimes when
there's something out of place it almost
takes longer for someone to realize that
something is out of place because you
sort of have this idea in your brain
that this is going to be the same every
single day and this sort of relates to
the concept of situational awareness now
when it comes to something like driving
around I think that people are generally
not aware of their surroundings and are
too distracted just over the weekend
when I was driving back from Montreal
from miles away on highway 89 it's very
straight in some parts oh very curvy in
other parts as you're going through the
Vermont mountains but in some parts it's
straight and from miles away
I saw a car in the fast lane and just
people going into the slow lane to pass
the car and you can just tell from miles
away this is someone on their mobile
phone they have no idea that they're
going under the speed limit in the fast
lane they have no idea that they're
being passed in the slow lane by
numerous cars and case in point as I got
close from you know whatever it was a
mile away to half a mile to a quarter
mile drive by and there's someone
sitting there with one hand on the
steering wheel and looking at their
phone like this no idea the chaos that
they're creating and the unsafe
situation that they're creating on the
highway so I think that for different
reasons and in different situations
people are generally not aware enough of
what's going on around them and too
distracted by all sorts of different
things and they can be incredibly
dangerous too I mean the example that
always comes to my mind is people using
their phones while they're driving
and of course in most states now you
can't text while drivers going in the
right direction but you can still use
your phone to make calls and of course
you have to toggle with it for a little
bit
although navigation as well
interestingly in Vermont
there are signs all over the highway
saying hand-held device use prohibited
for drivers so that means even if you're
picking up your phone to dial a phone
number and or even holding the phone up
to your face or using it for music or
together that would not be allowed when
I made it all the more frustrating when
this guy was causing havoc on i-89 by
doing exactly that on public transit I
think there's a sort of deliberate not
paying attention that goes on for many
people in order to not get pulled into
you know there can be characters on on
public transit in New York and in Boston
you see many people sort of enter their
own world I don't think that's a new
thing because of mobile phones no
pictures from the 60s people on trains
everybody kept their head in a newspaper
but I think it is sort of deliberate
disconnecting from your surroundings you
don't want to get pulled into whatever
performer is going to be doing a dance
on the subway and then asking for change
or people that might be suffering from
some kind of mental illness and and
maybe we'll talk to whoever makes eye
contact and that might make someone feel
unsafe but people go into a cocoon on
public transit in another example that
doesn't have to do with technology so
much is people walking in groups
maybe they're at a very slow pace not to
be the warrior for the people next to
each other and a sidewalk yeah and you
have to make this dangerous or rude move
to try to get around them I cannot stand
the occupants of an abuse ragged walkers
yeah and I know people say oh New
Yorkers or rude Bostonians are rude in
New York City they would sometimes be
usually it was tourists because they're
not exactly sure where to go and they
would get off the off the subway and
stand for a cross right at the bottom of
the set of stairs the set of stairs that
hundreds of people per minute need to go
up in order to make it to work on time
and block the entire set of stairs as
they look around we go an uptown or
downtown I'm not really sure and it's
not a question of being impolite it's
every minute you do that there are
hundreds of people that you were
delaying on their way to work yeah and
everyone can tell you know maybe someone
has a tough time walking there to say
ORS in some way or not everyone that's
going to be polite to them and give them
all the time that they need but it's
oftentimes just people just being
oblivious entirely and well not
everybody politely our president thinks
it's funny to mock people who have
physical disabilities but most normal
people would do it yeah see another
thing that came to my mind is do you
listen to music
with headphones while walking around in
the city I don't because a lot of people
don't because they're in fear that maybe
some attacker will come up behind them
or selling and they're just not going to
be aware of their surroundings I know I
don't do that
I don't okay I took Laredo I typically
carry a book with me or read articles on
my phone but yeah that is a risk I'm
willing to take I'm willing to walk
around with headphones and also the
other thing that came to my mind was one
time I was texting while walking
it isn't as dangerous as texting while
driving but all I got to end up into one
of my chakras yeah and I nearly walked
right into a street sign yeah and
someone laughs at me people I've seen
people walk into doors because they're
texting while walking anyway the answer
penny is no people are not paying enough
attention